with kumail nanjiani and all them yeah
it was like him
and uh who there was a there's like a
whole with nate bargati was he in that
one i don't think so
i think it was him uh camille
uh did i say that already
um
pete holmes
uh
tj miller
tj miller yeah okay
and
others
yeah i mean you don't want your scene to
be doing too bad even though it gives
you a slight advantage
you want it to be uh
you don't you want to be succeeding when
everyone else is doing well and not
because no one else is going up but
still like
a good thing if there's less people and
then it's like oh i'm gonna get better
than them
and when they do start coming
yeah you can be that much better than
them yeah exactly you get you're getting
the workouts in
yeah kind of investing in yourself
constantly yeah
but um yeah i'm
i'm sad that the scene isn't like as
bumping as it once was but whatever yeah
i mean i think it's still it still is
bumping and it's not that it's not
it's not that it's not great it's just
like it it just i just noticed it comes
in these ebbs and flows and it's in a
seems like it's kind of an ebb and then
i'm sure it'll pick up again
uh pretty soon
yeah but it's it's still fun
it's hard to go out because of the heat
exactly i think that's the big part of
it is the heat yeah
that sucks
yeah the heat the heat is awful that's
why california is so great because it's
always great weather yeah but like new
york has shitty weather and they're
still rocking it
they're still killing it yeah new york
is like 90s
80s or something
where's a volume on my side uh down for
just for the listening yeah yeah just
down a little bit oh perfect
okay
thank you
hello hello
gotta get the audio right
make it louder
than it has to be
that's that's interesting so you have
your fans already
listening
yeah nice
yeah it's live yeah nice i like it
better that way yeah yeah
it's uh more feels like more that we're
doing something as opposed to if we're
just recording it and then putting it
out later it's like is this going to be
in or not
and then you're not as uh engaged
yeah it's like a performance yeah
yeah yeah it's like performing in front
of not like like a live audience it's
like uh
yeah well rogan used to do his
completely live too didn't he yeah
that's um
he doesn't do that anymore no it's
probably for the best
yeah i mean his is so big that like
you know if someone says something crazy
that could make the national news
so it makes sense
um but yeah i mean i don't think i'm big
enough to for it to really matter not
yet you know you have time
yeah
hopefully a lot of time or a little
whichever one when do you find either
way when do you think you'll be on joe's
podcast
three months really 14 days
for real
oh
well that's my good that's my as good of
a guess as i can make right now i have a
feeling you'll be on
within another within a year
and that's my guess yeah a year it's
good it's a lot more than my guess oh
sorry yeah you know three months and
13th in me third three months and 13
days
so uh what uh
where do you go up what do you think
about
doing comedy at in austin
i go up
i like going to
buzz mill
uh you know you've been of course buzz
middle and not rivers that's great that
one's great creek's a great audience
because it's like liberals or like young
people
that are all poor
and they're not like into clubbing
because usually when i when it was like
on friday nights
and it's like they don't want to go out
they don't want to like get drunk and do
stupid [ __ ] they want to like talk to
each other
and there's comedy i'm sure some of them
come for the comedy
but uh yeah it's a cooler crowd it's not
like a crowd that's like douchebags or
sorority princesses
it's like
intellectuals or like people that are
actually doing trying to do something
interesting with their lives
so i like buzz mill
but they didn't do they don't do their
friday mic anymore right yeah i know
they canceled that unfortunately they
used to do that that was one of the best
ones in town i loved going there
the uh yeah it was at like 11. yeah that
was fun yeah yeah they stopped doing
that because i think somebody
um
somebody was
after the mic was over somebody like a
musician went up or somebody went up and
just started screaming into the
microphone
and making a lot of ruckus and someone
made a noise complaint and then uh they
just they can't the venue canceled the
mic
well if that's all it took for them to
cancel the mic i don't think they were
really on board with it anyway yeah i
know i think it was they were probably
just looking for a reason to so yeah
like whenever we were there like the
staff would be really brisk with us
yeah yeah
they'd be like excuse me they'd like be
carrying like 17 cups at once yeah yeah
i don't think they were really fond of
us doing that but it doesn't make sense
though because you have like 40 people
buying beers and and drinks so i feel
like it'd be good for business but
i mean i think they're doing fine
anyways i don't think they don't i feel
like they don't think they would that
they need us it's like an arrogance sort
of thing
yeah or just like we bring in like
people anyways we don't need you guys
yeah
well do you know that there was that old
guy that would operate the sound board
what was his deal did he work there
i don't know yeah
just remember he was just a weirdo just
in the corner yeah it was i would try
like talking to him and he
he didn't want anything he didn't want
any of it he would just sit and watch
but you don't want to socialize no not
at all
that's the only kind of socializing he
wants is like staring behind a like
metaphorical
glass
he doesn't want to interact he just
wants to watch other people yeah i think
so that's probably it he just wants to
sit and watch the performances
and that makes sense
it's better to just watch than to engage
in it and then get all emotionally
invested it's like
what he is what's going on inside his
brain is like pure and beautiful and he
doesn't want to
ruin it with uh other people yeah
um but yeah i mean i feel that way
sometimes yeah buzz mill or at other
mics where i'm like i don't want to talk
to these people
well that's actually one that's one nice
thing about being going to an open mic
or anything comedy is you can you can
kind of you can go and be somewhere and
be with people that you know and but you
don't necessarily have to like socialize
with them
so you like be around people
just kind of be what you can be by
yourself and with it with people at the
same time so this is kind of nice yeah
just kind of meditate on what you're
seeing and
yeah just yeah
at the at the mics yeah
the mics and just shows and they're
going to the creek or something like
that
yeah louis ck
when he was talking about horace and
pete that's that's how he described a
bar
yeah the bar is a place where people
can
both
be around people
but also
be kind of alone at the same time
but yeah
someone said you need more windows
yeah there's there's a lot of windows in
this place i don't know
someone said phantom power so i turned
the phantom power on i don't know what
that does oh is that because they can't
hear or i don't know
they said it's working this time
okay um but yeah i mean
i like
uh buzz mill i just think it's uh
not the ideal space
but the the crowds are good because
they're cool people like young people
but they don't expect comedy
and uh you can get them like in a more
honest place
they didn't go there for comedy
um
but yeah i mean i i think like
it's sad that they don't do it because
it's cool to just have
whatever just people hanging out and
talking but there is no
uh upward trajectory for that you don't
like get on hbo for hanging out and
talking really well
like if you have a avenue for all that
socializing to go down and to improve
i think
it's made way more worthwhile than just
their sights are so low it's just
they're just trying to run a good bar
and they don't have any
like aspirations or thoughts about the
larger picture they're just like we're
trying to run a bar really good
but you could use that bar to create a
scene
to create art to create uh thoughts
and uh social exchanges that could be
powerful
and instead they're just using it to try
to make more money and try to pay their
rent like
peasants little rats
so
this is buzz mill you're saying
well not buzz mills but just people in
general
they're like why do you have to do this
comedy right now we're trying to
further our empty lives that we're not
doing anything
but uh yeah i'm sure that some of them
are doing cool things they want to talk
to each other yeah no i guess that's
kind of that whole thing that whole idea
is like
the idea of uh
it's like
being cynical of of
entertainment or art or anything like
that
in favor of uh just making more money or
just following this the stride of
what you have to do to to do that yeah
but it's not ideal
um it's just weird just me to see those
people that are like bar backing or
bartending and they like take their job
really seriously and they're like watch
out i'm moving this garbage can and they
make everyone pay attention to them as
they move their garbage can oh yeah yeah
it's like is this really what you want
attention for there's nothing else that
you do that deserves attention
yeah i don't know i is it attention do
you think they're looking for attention
just i think to be that's part of it i
think they want to be the best at their
job no matter what it is even if it's
just moving a garbage can around and
it's like
this shouldn't be your culmination this
shouldn't be the
your magnum opus like do this job humbly
or else i think you're a loser like it
has the opposite effect i like demanding
respect and attention
for this stupid job but it's like
if you did it like a normal person like
how this job should be done then
i would respect you even more because
i'm like oh this person probably does
something on his free time that's
worthwhile but if you put all your
marbles and like
grabbing empty drinks and kicking people
out of a bar
and it's like oh this is all you have
you're pathetic
yeah i mean
i could see that
when but there is something to that
though sometimes when someone cares
cares about their job it's like
there's almost like there's almost like
a i think a piece of
something to like uh respect in that but
yeah if they're being like a dick about
it yeah it's yeah it's tough if it's
coming from a bad place yeah yeah but if
you're like really good at bar keeping
bartending and you're like washing each
glass and like making sure everything's
clean and nice for the customers then
that's
that's a good thing
um but i just feel like a lot of people
think that they should be the main
character of every scene and every part
of their life yeah yeah i see you see
that a lot in like coffee shops and
stuff
yeah people who take your stuff yeah
yeah it's
yeah i noticed that actually around in a
lot of in austin because i'm from
connecticut um where are you from
originally again seattle new york
seattle new jersey i don't know if it's
the same but this the
i actually think the people in
connecticut like that part are actually
the service workers are actually nicer
up there than they are here i mean
they're they're still they're still here
they demand respect yeah exactly that's
the thing is they demand respect here
like because i don't know what it is
i'll give it to you but if you demand it
then yeah i have no choice then
i it's i don't want to give or i don't
want to be you know
i want to be able to give it on my own
volition not because you forced me yeah
yeah you up north it's a little bit more
they're a little bit more quick and kind
of curt but yeah here it's yeah it's
like kind of there's a little bit more
of like a demand respect like and also
like um
it's almost like a little essence of
like oh i don't need to be doing this
that sort of thing
yeah i mean but
but uh
yeah what is your thought what are your
thoughts on tipping
like tipping for like coffees and stuff
like that i wish it wasn't a thing i
wish you just paid how much things cost
and then they got paid a living wage
i think it's really uh coercive to be
like oh did i do enough for you and was
i pleasing to you could you please give
me the required tippage
and i think like 20
is more
than what would be if it was in
integrated into the system
i think yeah there probably is more they
make us pay more yeah because 20 is
pretty
well do they always i always wondered
how that works does the full 20 usually
almost always go to the to that server
for the table
it really depends on the restaurant
sometimes they pull it sometimes it goes
to the individual sometimes
the restaurant gets it and they give out
a little bit to the workers
but yeah i think it's archaic and it's
just another sign of america's dark past
of like
lower class and
slavery and all that yeah because they
don't do they don't do tipping in uh
in europe
or asia or asia yeah
yeah i mean
i guess it's
i mean i guess like french people french
waiters have terrible service sometimes
unless you get into fine dining in which
case it's an art form
it's like the major leagues there of
waiter waitering
but yeah i don't think it's a good thing
i think it's weird that you go around
just giving people money
i think it should be done
uh you know not so overtly it should be
like
money should be handled you know like in
a more
uh civilized way just under the table
like
yes you deserve human dignity and
you know a living wage and you don't
have to make it so obvious that you're
like giving these people peanuts to live
on
uh if we all had like a decent life then
i don't think it'd be
like such a big deal that people have to
get tips and have to make a big show of
giving the poor money
yeah yeah no i
i think like tipping at a restaurant is
fine i mean i get it but like when it's
like when you buy like or when i buy
like a coffee for like four dollars then
it's like an extra they ask if you want
to tip an extra dollar or like two or
three it's just kind of excessive like
it adds up
yeah
everywhere it's like there's a tip
option now like even if there's no
waiter exactly what am i paying
well the craziest one i ever saw was i
went to a place and like there was a
cashier and then he flipped the whole
tablet towards me and then i chose what
i wanted and i set it all up and then
paid and then there was a tip option
after that
so he's demanding a tip for flipping
over the ipad yeah yeah so i was like
shouldn't the tip just be like a
discount like shouldn't i tip myself
because you know i just did the thing
but i get the tip yeah it's just like
stuff like that where i'm gonna tip
myself and then if you kind of if you
were if you like uh have a problem with
it
then it you kind of you seem like a like
elitist or
whatever yeah i mean you're trying to
take tackle a huge issue individually
yep
i went to a grocery store and they gave
me a receipt in new york and they had a
little tip option for a grocery store
yeah what did you do you just sat here
yeah i mean if you want extra money just
make things cost a little bit extra it's
just like do you have too much money and
want to give it to me that's crazy i've
never seen that for a grocery store yeah
interesting new york so yeah
they have like little stores that are
like barely legal
it's just like in a a hidden hole in the
wall
so yeah they get to do whatever the [ __ ]
they want and they're like well if we
put this little line
uh on the receipt sometimes we get extra
money so why wouldn't they
but now it's like we're conditioned to
be like oh there's a extra line let me
give them more money so now we have to
be extra vigilant and be like oh
sometimes just because they demand a tip
doesn't mean they should give it and
then you have to think about it and then
less people get tipped
yeah
yeah
why what did you think about tipping
well i was gonna say this person said i
don't have to tip
yeah jay
that's true you don't have to you don't
have to um
but what did you think about tipping
well as you're gonna say like the um the
whole
like a restaurant i get it like you know
so i'm just used to it but it's like
it's the stuff with like coffee and
sandwiches and like from food trucks and
stuff it just adds up if you keep
tipping like yeah i only tip if there's
a waiter involved if it's just like a
food truck yeah food truck then i don't
they just yell at me to get my food
but it's weird like why is it just a
waiter that we think gets a tip yeah
yeah it's like called it's a cultural
thing yeah yeah
for some reason they don't pay their
waiters enough so i have to pay them
but yeah if uh they don't have uh
the money and the power to have waiters
then i don't feel like you deserve a tip
you're already running a streamlined
operation anyways
but yeah i mean i yeah i don't i don't
think it's a good thing
i think things should cost however much
they cost and you should pay it and that
should be it shouldn't have to like put
your emotions into the receipt
like this guy gave me this much service
let me give him financial reward
it's like
a a pain to ask to think about
and it should already be like because we
don't have any basic uh
social safety nets like we make
ourselves feel better like oh i tipped
so that way i don't have to vote for
universal health care
it's like why don't you just like treat
people
correctly efficiently on a grand scale
like instead of having everyone
individually get tipped just have
everyone get universal health care
and then we won't have to uh go around
giving little
pittances to the poor
yeah
it's true
anyways what do you think about biden
giving a speech in front of a red
backdrop i uh i saw just a like a image
of that i didn't i don't know the full
story what was that uh
what was the that is just a
bad look
but what was
so that was the con look because i
didn't know what the context was he was
just giving a speech in front of a red
background
independence hall in philadelphia what
was the speech about it uh it was about
the danger of domestic terrorism or
whatever okay
yeah because i saw like a screenshot of
him with behind the red background yeah
because it looked what kind of were
people saying it looked kind of like
nazi-ish
yeah but honestly if you're afraid of
biden then you're a [ __ ]
the free yeah well yeah i mean i'm i'm
not afraid of them i don't even really
watch the news or listen i don't have
twitter i don't look at twitter okay so
but it's like yeah if you're really
afraid of are you are like are these
people like freaking out like yeah
they're talking about they're talking so
much [ __ ] about biden like oh he's so
weak he's so feeble he's such an idiot
and then they're like oh look he's in
front of a right background it's like
they want him to be scary and
weak at the same time whatever yeah
however they want to make fun of him
it's just whatever it takes to make fun
of him yeah no it doesn't make sense
they contradict themselves because it's
like yeah he's this mastermind the
who is putting
whatever
with the vaccines and everything but i
don't know and then it's like is he he's
old and feeble it's just two different
yeah i don't know for me i just think
he's like it doesn't make sense the
whole thing doesn't make sense it's like
he's so uh he's like 80 or 79 78
so it's just
i just can't believe that he's like the
president and he's like that old he's so
old
he's waited i bet he was like oh well my
chance is over i can never get it and
then i was like wait a minute
well yeah i was thinking about it he's
as old as like paul mccartney so like
he's
he was like
he was my age when when jfk was
assassinated
yeah
like that's crazy like and then he's
been if you think about it too like just
when when do you think you're like an
old person
like an old like an adult like 50 yeah
like 30 years past that in 1990 he's
been an old person for a long time for a
long time yeah
yeah that's our system is uh
it's an archaic system where we still
worship founding fathers in the
constitution
so that we don't have to think and
create a better system but preserve the
one we have now and the only people that
are good at that are the oldest people
the young people are not good at the job
of preserving the system they'll want to
change it too much so we elect old
people that are going to keep things the
same because that's what we think we
need we just need to preserve things
yeah yeah i mean it is pretty crazy
because
he's old then there's nancy pelosi she's
older than him i think she's like 81 or
80. and then a lot of the justices mitch
mcconnell yeah yep
um
yeah
i mean
it's the old that have all the power and
if you look at the income
of our uh different age groups the old
have all the money
they have all the wealth
so it's like they're parasitizing the
young
even though they're gonna die soon and
they don't need it they just it's just a
habit to them to take because that's
what they did to third world countries
and now they're doing it to their young
it's like a diseased parasite well
i always wanted this because they you
know they're like what seven they're
they're old
how do they have the energy to do all
this stuff you know like what do you
think it is that they
they do just they just have it are they
just like yeah i mean
with modern medicine i don't think it's
like
they're just like normal people
they just have slightly less energy but
you can still do whatever you want to do
yeah even if you're old
yeah
i don't know in a way it is kind of
inspiring though because if i'm like on
the weekend or if i'm like uh feeling
lazy
it's like you know
i just think like
the president of the united states is
yeah you have 17 60 years
to do whatever you want but even that
but it's just like
just like if i'm feeling like if i'm
feeling like if i'm feeling like uh weak
or something yeah at least you're not
joe biden it kicks joe biden's feeling
way worse than you and he's running an
entire country you think he's doing
worse than me
yeah i mean in terms of how you feel
no yeah like feeling like yeah health
wise yeah maybe i don't know are you
unhealthy no i try to be healthy then
you're healthier than biden all right
yeah i guess so i saw him fall off his
bike
that was interesting yeah he looked
pretty uh fit though on the bike at
least yeah
he looks good he's pretty fit for an
american 80 year old yeah i don't know i
don't really follow uh
the uh
he's not running anything i don't know i
i can never tell whether or not i should
look at the chat or not but what do you
prefer do i do i not look at it or
whatever well if you're in the middle of
a thought don't look at it okay
but um
i don't know what was i gonna say
you feel good
oh yeah yeah
yeah no i don't even really i'm very
indifferent about politics i don't
really follow it i don't really i've
never really
had a horse in any race
yeah yeah you're more focused on other
things yeah yeah i'm more like uh just
open-minded kind of center
yeah you don't pay attention to politics
not really no yeah that's fine what do
you pay attention to
uh mostly stand-up comedy yeah just yeah
it's just that's my big focus right now
so writing jokes and stuff yeah writing
jokes just kind of figuring out what
isn't it weird like you're saying you're
focused on comedy but comedy is like
looking outward so you're focused on
looking at life in the world so yeah
which part of life in the world are you
looking at and focused on what's the big
thing right now that i'm struggling with
is
like
i'm focused on comedy but what i have to
do is
it's kind of a
it's kind of like a paradox where i have
to
actually step away from it and do other
stuff to then get the material and
that's the problem having is not doing
the other stuff
to like to get the material
like living more life and like yeah
doing things making plans you got to do
things more yeah do more things kind of
get more interest that's why i've i've
started i'm trying to limit the amount i
look at my phone and instagram and stuff
and
hoping that i can start to uh
do other stuff and
find other apps like i'm like i'm
learning piano right now
i'm trying to trying to do that but
and otherwise i'm just i work i work a
lot yeah that's good that comedy is
making you think more consciously about
living your life yeah yeah as opposed to
just like droning on and not really
worried about you know because if you're
doing comedy people are looking at you
you hopefully you have an interesting
life that you can share
and uh if you don't have an interesting
life then it's like what are you doing
up there so it's like sort of forces you
to be an interesting person
yeah yeah it definitely helps you know
especially with stories i'm not really i
don't have never really told stories on
stage but
you know you look at some of these
comics that have led really interesting
and have been interesting and a lot of
their material is just uh
is stories
and that's they just get those from
experiencing it and then being able to
convey it in a way that's funny
yeah i mean even if you're a storyteller
it's like still a lot of the stories
that you tell aren't funny and you have
to go figure out which ones
are funny and aren't yeah yeah because
if it was easy for them then everyone
would be a storyteller and then all the
best comics would be storytellers but
joke tellers are a large portion of the
comedy community
yeah no it's like there's storytellers
but they storytellers still have to be
funny there's some
comics
it's almost like every storytelling
comic is funny that i don't think
there's a lot that aren't
necessarily funny
um but like there's a lot of great like
tom segura this great storyteller
microbiglia
john mullaney is really good at that
but i i wish i can get down to that
avenue to do that because that's i think
that's like really complex stand-up is a
story but i'm not there yet i don't
think i'm mostly doing one-liners and
kind of trying to do bits
yeah i mean you have to have an
interesting story to tell but i think
even more important than that is like
your ability to think that it's
interesting yeah you have to yeah that's
the thing is i have to think the person
has the thing who's saying it yes i
think it's interesting you can't expect
them to and it's like a way of looking
at the world when you go through like a
story you're like oh what is the most
interesting way to look at this or like
being so firmly in your perspective that
you uh know how you feel about certain
things yes just being open-minded and
going through things as
uh as they come to you and judging how
you should feel to get the best results
but i feel like even if you're telling
jokes you're still telling a story
you're still telling a philosophy about
how you look at the world which can be
even more
powerful than like a strict storyteller
that's like on the nose about oh when
you're talking to a flight attendant
this is how
a funny thing to say would be
but if you're telling a joke you're like
look at the bird uh
and a tree it looks like a taco or
whatever then that you're telling a
perspective of how you can be talking to
a flight attendant and look at the world
in a funny way so just because you're
not directly on the nose telling people
like what
happened in your life and what what what
transpired in your life like as a story
you could still be telling people
like things about you like mitch hedberg
yeah like he never told a story that
much
like he told a few stories but
uh
we still know his perspective and we
still can embody his persona wherever we
feel fit through his jokes because it's
his
it's him it's coming from him and it's
how he views things yeah and he's a good
at what he does yeah he is he's good at
uh encapsulating his perspective
yeah no i mean uh
him and uh
i mean george carlin never really told
stories he did most he did bits like he
never did autobiographical
stories but you could definitely tell
that that was him you know that's him
yeah that's you can see that's that's
that's george carlin
um
yeah the same guys who do both yeah if
you want to tell stories and that's all
is required to tell stories and then you
put in the work to make it happen and
then you're a storyteller yeah but if
you really like stories that much you'd
probably be telling them already
you think by now yeah i mean that's fine
if i don't i guess i guess i don't
really necessarily want to do stories i
mean my favorite comic is louie so i
would love to be able to do
he does stories but he does uh my
favorite louis bits are obvious like
observational bits yeah so i guess i
honestly would rather be more like an
observational
community like or like a jim gaffigan
where you take that where you make the
observation of something
and you break it down yeah i feel like
that's really cool because then you
actually are uh telling people things
that they can take home with them like
yes it's like an actual thing that i saw
as opposed to like oh we know that nick
ran into a
uh you know a mexican person on a
scooter one day and that's how you
reacted i guess that's true i guess i
don't really miss i guess yeah it's not
stories that i want to get into it's
more bits and uh observational
observational comedy that's like one
that's my favorite stand-up comedy i
think is observational one-liners are
great i love i love dimitri martin
um i don't know if you're familiar with
him yeah something like that yeah
yeah yeah he's one he's out of all out
of a lot of the one-liner guys he's uh
he's probably my favorite yeah he's like
50.
and he looks yeah yeah he's old now
right
well he's always been old for a while
yeah but uh he has a great bit uh
because we were talking about comedy
clubs he was talking about the best
comedy clubs are built
in a way where it's like low ceiling few
escapes
it's crowded it's like the best comedy
rooms are the worst places to escape
from a fire yeah yeah yeah that's
dimitri marin joke right mm-hmm yeah
it's good yeah he isn't so true then he
has a great bit about uh
about silent letters i can't do it
justice but it's so cleverly written
about like uh
like you're a g get out of here
no be quiet
we'll just tell them we're foreigners
like in the word for like some like in
the word foreigners i didn't do it
justice but he he's a great joke writer
one of my favorite joke writers of all
time is andre martin i mean i think
those are great too
uh one-liners and observational and
stories are great it's just i uh i don't
like the hierarchy of like people like
stories are the best yeah yeah yeah i
get that well it's like yeah it's like
comparison
comedy blues is better than whatever
yeah
it's just more artistic but it's less
translatable it's less relatable
um but yeah i mean i think that uh
whatever way it comes out for you is
great like i don't necessarily want to
hear a story every time we just are used
to one-liners and observational comedy
because that's like what most people do
but if everyone was telling stories at
every mic no yeah no i don't think it's
like the yeah it'd be exhausting because
stories are usually long and boring and
they take a while to just get started no
if it was all story like get to a
punchline tell a one-liner already no i
it is annoying when you see people uh
just
uh
just uh
start a story and have tried it before
yeah and they just tape her off and it's
just people especially if you don't get
them in the beginning yeah if you don't
get them in the beginning then you you
lose interest
if you don't get them in the beginning
then it's like oh my god how much more
of this yeah i know and then people just
look at you like you're like the worst
thing yeah i clock out of those stories
quickly if if someone's on stage they
start one i just i'm not even paying
attention at some point i hate when i'm
on stage and there's just someone just
dead
dead facing me
oh really yeah i don't even dude i don't
even look at the crowd i look above them
i'm like autistic
well they're heads that's not the point
i was making yeah that sucks that's a
good way to handle it but it's like what
is like are you never aware of your face
are you like that are you never talking
to people like is this a a way that you
talk to people you just like they give
them nothing they just give you like a
dead like a like a what is like a dirty
face or it's yeah they just give me
nothing and they it's like your face is
expressing something you must know that
you must know that people look at your
face and then have a reaction based on
it and you're still not gonna give me
anything yeah so it's like yeah it's
it's the worst because uh
then you're like forced to not look at
them or something
you have to come up with a solution i
want to yell at them but that might ruin
the show it's like this one guy killed
tony always shows up and he always
is like just frowning
really he shows up every week
and he's just sitting like does he sit
close up front yeah he's in the very
close
and it's just like
you
must know that this is not a good
thing for people to see and that i'm
looking at you yeah and that you're just
making the show worse now yeah
but yeah that sucks i i actually i don't
even
i was an audience member and i'm and i
had noticed the comics looking at me i
actually that's why i kind of sit in the
back of the room because i don't i don't
like that feeling exactly
if you can't handle that [ __ ] then sit
in the back don't sit in there no it's
exactly what i said i can help you face
me i let people who are because there
are more people who wear their heart on
their sleeve and they're more laugh they
laugh more i'm more of a quiet i like
just kind of being quiet when i watch
stand up a lot of the time so i i think
it's more fair to them if i stand in the
back because i don't want to like have
them especially because you're a
comedian yeah exactly so i prefer to
stand in the back but like when the
comics looking at me i
usually just give them like a little uh
just a nice like
not necessarily laughing but like you
want them to see it just like a
welcoming you want this
yeah um yeah you want them to see a
pleasant face and you want to help the
show out hopefully by giving them
something pleasant to look at
and uh
it's like weird if someone uses their
face just to give nothing it's like
you're not just there to watch you're
also being watched
and yeah
yeah just act like other parts of your
life like do you go to like a
like a parent-teacher conference and
then when the teachers talk to you just
try to look like a goddamn
stone-faced soldier like look miserable
like you're not enjoying yourself like
in other social situations you don't do
yeah you don't do that like a restaurant
or at a barber shop or i mean imagine
being at a barber shop and someone's got
these guys cutting your hair and you're
just like you're looking miserable yeah
you want to look like you're having a
good time so they don't like that freak
out or anything that are really relaxed
in some way but some people like look at
comedy and they're like oh you need to
make me laugh so i'm going to be as
miserable as possible so that i get the
highest
high
because if you're just
miserable and then you become happy then
it's like a bigger bigger jump that you
made and they're getting more for their
money oh you think it's like they're
they're like you gotta sell me like well
they're not trying emotionally okay
they're just like i'm tired of trying to
make myself happy i'm just gonna not try
at all i'm just gonna be miserable as
[ __ ] yeah yeah and then you have to do
all the work god yeah
no i i don't uh for that reason that's
why i don't look at the
audience is because i don't like to look
at their reaction i love it when i don't
see this like when the lights are
blinding i don't really see anybody
that's my favorite yeah you can just
perform yeah yeah just perform
not even not even see anybody's face
yeah that's what a lot of comedians say
that they want
i just you know i just got used to being
able to see people just because that's
how it normally is no i think it is
normal too i just from hearing other
comics talking
most comics and just from seeing them on
stage they ten of
all types of comics they tend to look at
i mean i've seen people look at every
single person in the room like
like scan each person and really get a
sense of who's in there and who's paying
attention i think it helps because then
i think anyway yeah
then it's like oh i'm talking to someone
this is a conversation
and it makes you perform it better
because you're actually saying it to
someone
but you know it could it could be
distracting especially if people have
like
this one person never left at anything
and then you develop this sort of
relationship with this one audience
member yeah yeah and you always look to
them but hold it against them i try to
use those people like if there's someone
who laughs a lot then i'll look at them
when i'm feeling like oh that joke
didn't do that well then i'll use them
to boost myself up yeah and then if i'm
killing so hard that i need to be
brought down to earth
then i look at the guy that's like
depressed all the time yeah so i try to
use them
you know to to modulate my emotions and
look at the proper audience members to
get the emotion that i need
but yeah even if you're giving me sour
face i can still use that to help
the overall production performance yeah
you kind of you use it to your advantage
in a way like uh yeah or just look over
them like you do yeah autistically yep
yeah
the uh
when you're when you're doing like a
like an arena
or uh it's like a big venue like that
do you
how
close like i always wondered this like
how uh
when you're on stage and you're looking
out what do you see immediately is there
like a space is there like a distance
between you and the next audience member
is or is it are the people still like
right up right up to the stage the
seating arrangements are different
sometimes it's in the round you know
there's a stage and then the audience is
like there it's like a little gap
um
rashad evans was in the front row once
and then like it's easy to get caught up
with the people right here right like
right directly in front of you
but there's like 5 000 people up
so if you're just looking at these
people then 5 000 people aren't getting
that same experience
and a lot of them are watching the tv so
it doesn't really matter but yeah i try
to look up more because it's easy to
look down i already look down at the
people
and perform like it's a vulcan but yeah
i try to look up because that's there's
more people there and
so weird wow
when that uh that sound of of laugh of
laughter and clap is it do you feel it
like
is it how loud is it is it is it crazy
or is it
like is there any like noticeable
difference yeah it's like you're surfing
it's like a large amount of energy
and just let it channel through you and
inform your act and
give you enough juice for the next bit
what's uh
what's your favorite
uh venue you've done so far
um probably the mgm grand garden arena
las vegas yeah that was fun i think i
had a good set there
so that was fun how many people is that
but usually there's the same as you
usually in the round and
you know it feels the same the last one
that i did in salt lake city was fun too
it was felt more like
uh like
like uh
like a half hazard arena like it was
sort of like
cobbled together it's like a minor
league hockey league
hockey teams
uh stadium
but it still held like 14 000 people or
whatever crazy
so it was uh
it was sort of like
like awesome but also like
it felt like commercial like
mass-produced
kind of arena but
there's still an arena damn
yeah
14 000 people that's insane
that's crazy
yeah i mean it's in the round so
you know one side is like 3 000 people
or 4 000 people 4 000 4 000 400
so it's like you're performing in front
of four theaters
so one theater is over here now let's go
to the next theater the next theater so
you get to choose and and do you go out
cold are you the first guy to go out
yeah wow joe rogan gives me an
introduction
they hear his voice which helps yeah
yeah
and then i go up and then i just walk
around the stage with my arms up
until this
until you know they stopped roaring and
they're like finally it's happening
and they get all that out of their
system and then i swear at them and
get them going and
attack them or something
and how much time do you usually do does
it change
okay
um yeah i mean
what do you think about like
the progression like open mics and then
shows and then
you know
feature spots and all that
i uh i think it's i think it's uh
it's just the way it is i i
i still enjoy doing it it's fun to me i
still i've been doing i've been in
austin for about two years now
uh doing open mics
and i've made headway doing a lot of
roast battles i've been doing those
uh
i have one tomorrow um
but just the track just
is it's fine i i'm just keep going along
keep doing the mics uh yeah as many as
many as i can
um
and just kind of see what happens you
like going up at open mics and talking
to people and making them laugh
yeah yeah i enjoy it
yeah it's a weird thing when they're
like next up nick roche yeah yep and you
get up there and it's like hey it's my
turn
and it's i mean i don't know it's just
inherently funny because it's like why
are we doing this yeah situationally it
makes no sense really it's it's weird i
actually i get to a point too where it's
like because i do them so often it's
just a habit it's habitual it's like
taking a shower or something you just
after work i go do a mic
and
it's it's weird like after i finish one
you know i'll do three minutes four
minutes
and it's just kind of
sometimes it gets the points where it's
just like going through the motions
and it's i still enjoy it like i still
it's still pleasant to be yeah but i
still have to like tell my like be
introspective and kind of think of way
to like
what can i do to
to to progress
it's kind of like it's kind of like uh
you don't want to process it
yeah well yeah i mean you don't want to
zone out too much and go through the
motions but if you're going to have to
go through the motions with anything it
might as well be something that you like
doing you like doing and it's like but
doing it you can get better at
and doing it is better than not doing it
at all so right but
if you have too many times where you're
just zoning out and on autopilot
then it's not good yeah because then
it's like why are you up there you're
wasting time i'm bored yeah
but uh hopefully if you can enjoy it and
you know
even if you know you're not feeling it
you can still be like well i'm up here
talking to people like i can see
whatever i want i can use these people
to help my
emotional state then
you figure out how to do that and
instead of just like going into the
normal paths just try to
you know use whatever you have in front
of you to
the
you know to the highest degree possible
because then if you don't do it someone
else is going to use the audience like
that and they're going to be like wow
that guy was better so you might as well
like try to learn how to you know
use that audience to
figure things out about yourself or
improve yourself and stuff
but yeah it's a powerful tool that we
get to do every day yeah and people are
like it's shitty well it should be
shitty it's like a crazy thing to demand
of people yeah to ask for their
attention it is shitty yeah and it's uh
the worst one i i had a really awful one
the other day some of them were good but
uh like i did uh this wasn't an open mic
this was a show it was a barrels and
amps that was fun um but some open mics
are great like uh snail hey i like snail
haven that's uh one that a nikkor corey
yeah runs but i did one open mic um
i won't say but it's like a but it was a
bar bar bar mic and it's just like one
of those mics where you're doing the bar
you're doing comedy to a bar
like a bar of people yeah and nobody
wants to listen everyone's looking at
the tv they're drinking they're trying
to forget the work day they had their
tvs on of course yeah yeah yeah it was
like i hate that that's the worst yeah
so like you do one of those and it's
like you literally i'm you're just i'm
just talking i'm doing jokes and you're
getting nothing like there was this one
drunk guy at the end of the bar who was
just like
he was listening and he just kept going
like talk louder talk louder i can't
hear you
it's like uh
yeah you have mike yeah
yeah he was you know in a way he was
endearing because you didn't want to
listen but he was just uh
it was just a
just one of those mics
yeah
i mean that sucks it sucks because
you're being so vulnerable and it's like
the more vulnerable you are the better
you are at it but then if you're
vulnerable
and then it's not reciprocated and it's
just like they just trash you because
they didn't expect it and they don't
care yeah and it's like you get hardened
and then you don't you aren't able to be
vulnerable next time
yeah you get kind of jaded in a way yeah
that's the thing i want to do more is i
want to get a little bit more like
i guess
more
i'm getting there i noticed that's one
thing i've improved in is getting looser
on stage but i want to get more loose
more looser and more confident that's
big that's important to me more myself
looser and more confident that's good
but i think it's just like it's so vague
that
maybe it's not the best thing to shoot
for because i know this guy who's like
funny he's like deadpan and quiet yeah
and now he's like trying to act out and
he's like trying to do voices and trying
to move around and it's like yeah that's
not
you
like i was still maybe maybe yeah i know
you're saying well it doesn't look very
natural yeah so it's like it just
you don't have to put in more energy you
don't have to shout and yell to be funny
the thing you should be
the thing you should be focused on is
being funny and not more energy
that more energy isn't necessarily funny
yeah that's that's a good point that is
true like yeah because you look at
someone like stephen wright who doesn't
have any energy yeah really at all but
mitch had berg yeah that is true yeah
there's like subtle things you can do to
make yourself more funny but i mean it's
good to experiment yeah good to like try
things that you aren't comfortable with
just to find out what your limits are
yeah
but yeah i uh i think like this uh
automatic reverence for energy and
storytellers is like
it's just like what an idiot thinks
comedy is
you think yeah it's just like the
layman's version of like oh yes i want
someone that's gonna you know do this
and this and this for me
it's like a [ __ ] telenovela or like
slapstick
like
i love lucy type of comedy yeah well
there's no right way to do it
yeah i mean there is no right way to do
it
yeah everyone does differently
yeah but uh i just i just don't like it
when people that are like good at one
thing are like no this isn't me i'm this
other thing that's better and it's like
i don't i don't i don't think that uh
not everyone should be doing the same
type of comedy
and no yeah i don't think so i don't
think everybody should be doing the same
type it's all depends on the person it
depends on the what the person who's
doing it wants to do and what they feel
more comfortable doing
let me try open
[Music]
that's so freaking hot in here
what do you what do you think
it's cool yeah
i think uh
anyone's saying anything
yeah i know it's
yeah it seems pretty
seems good yeah there's nothing crazy i
mean it's pretty tame it seems like a
nice nice chat
i mean i think it's good to like just
have a good conversation
and then let them talk about it than it
is to like just like look at what
they're saying yeah no i'm trying not
last time we played
last time i did your podcast i i kept
paying attention to it a lot
yeah uh this time i'm not really i'm
just
i glanced at it here and there
but um
trying to get it right in the center
i don't know it's not perfect but look
at the camera yeah
um
yeah i think it's it needs to be tilted
more towards my direction
anyways
so
the scene is
kind of an ebb it seems to me that's my
person that's my opinion feels like a
neb but you're open markers everyone's
like oh [ __ ] i guess
i guess i can't just
become famous overnight
yeah yeah i know it takes
it's a long it's a long journey i mean
you've been doing how old are you
33. and you've been doing comedy for
nine years yeah so
that's
yeah it seems like everyone's been doing
it around two to three years yeah i'm
four
okay
yeah it seems like everyone's the same
age
comedy wise yeah
um which is interesting and good
um but yeah um
a lot of people
haven't been doing it nine years which
is unfortunate
because i think if they did they'd be
funny and they'd be great at it
you're saying so it's just about
longevity yeah no that's really big it's
what i've come to appreciate too like a
lot of my favorite comics they don't
really i mean
comics who succeed young it's a very
small amount of people it's like the
pete davidson eddie murphy
um
and yeah i can't really taylor tomlinson
she started when she was 16 and um
yeah they usually quit dave chappelle
hasn't
but yeah it's usually if they get good
it's like oh i'm bored with it now
they move on to the next thing yeah or
they have like certain parts of their
personality that they want to hide now
that they don't want to be open with and
stand up is very like revealing so they
just quit so they can
be hide themselves what do you think it
is for someone who who blows up when
they're 20 21 do you think that's like
it's raw talents or do you think it's uh
they're it's they're exposing themselves
so much
is it like bravery or what do you think
it is
um i think like it's like uh in tune
with what makes you funny
and you're aware of it and it doesn't
make you sad
like if you can be aware of what makes
you funny and that's a source of power
and you can think about it in the right
way
and you can formulate jokes and have
clear thoughts and ideas and you're not
lying to yourself
so that you have to go through an extra
filter
to come up with thoughts then i think it
just helps
i think some people have the right
mental state
that everything lines up so that they
can perform like how they do i think
that's great
yeah yeah it doesn't always happen and
sometimes you have to work on your
perspective and work on who you are
and it gets better and then
uh what you think is funny lines up with
what the audience thinks is funny
yeah
i um it's yes it seems like
it's it almost seems like a
eight to ten with
ten years
do you think is there a number or is it
different for everyone like if you were
to guess like how many years it takes to
till someone gets like traction
like in terms of
being a professional
yeah
do you think there's a
you can count you can kind of put it in
years or is it just kind of one of those
things that's just
up in the air just
there is no way
well
i don't i think a lot of people want to
put it in years
and i don't think you should
i think you should just
do it and know that it's going to take a
while but
you shouldn't be like oh in 14 months i
should be famous
it's not cut and dry it's not
mathematical it's just you know you got
to keep improving and doing it over and
over again
that process takes a while and to put
like a number on it so you can just
count down the days until you do it i
think is
i don't think it's the right mentality i
don't think you can get 10 years if
you're doing it that way
yeah
yeah the
i think i've heard people say it takes
like 20 years to make a great great
comedian i think louis said that um but
i don't know
yeah i mean he's been doing it 30 years
so obviously yeah he would say that yeah
yeah a lot of guys it seems like just a
lot of my favorite comics it seems like
they don't really start to hit their
stride till their late 30s
yeah it's an old man's game yeah
um
yeah i think that's what i like about it
is that it's not just pure just whatever
you happen to be born with it's not like
a supermodel or like an athlete where
it's like oh you happen to be born this
way good job
it's like a work something that you work
towards something that's in your head
that you work intellectually at
and i think that's much more rewarding
and
a you know a larger part of being human
than it is to run fast we're not fast
runners we're good thinkers
to reward you know usain bolt for
running as fast as like the slowest
bunny rabbit isn't like
excelling at what we do best it's just
what we like because we're uneducated
and
we're powerless and weak and dumb and we
don't know
what our success is uh
in uh
because of
i think it's like um
we uh don't treasure the intellect and
likes intelligence because we don't have
a an economy that is fair or
meritocratic so we're like oh yeah
running fast that's like the closest we
can get to meritocracy because our
existing power structure is like all
about who can take from who and who
started out with the biggest stick that
they can whack each other with yes one
thing that i've noticed
out of being out of college i've only
been out for two years but just from
witnessing things and just kind of
seeing just from observing i've come to
really appreciate that success a lot of
it isn't is not
necessarily skill it's not necessarily
being smarter being better at something
a lot of it and not even necessarily
networking a lot of it is just
people
uh just taking what they want
yeah like it's hard to put but like it's
a lot of it's just
a lot of it is ambition and a lot of it
is just people diving head first into
some lack of morality
it can be that yeah it depending on how
you do it if you do it
if you do it badly yeah absolutely look
at all the richest men
they didn't get there by sharing and
being nice yeah
they bought
they undercut their competition
um but yeah i mean i think a lot of like
comedic success and you know artistic
success like in music is
through hard work
and effort and you know purity of
uh vision and motivation
and i think any other success like
athletic success or like supermodels or
instagram models
it's like that's
toxic like that's doesn't feel good
uh it doesn't make you feel like a human
being and they're constantly insecure
and
shitty about it
uh yeah like being born like something a
nate kind of yeah
yeah that's part of the reason i try to
stop i try to stop looking at instagram
as much
uh just looking at that stuff
yeah yeah
i mean i think instagram is just a tool
that shows us our society and what we
really have a problem with is how our
society is structured if we were living
in a better society like in star trek
and everyone was working on a skill and
they were showing it off on instagram
then instagram wouldn't be a bad thing
but
none of us are doing anything we're all
just like toiling away and wasting our
lives and like a few people have found a
way to make the jump to you know invest
in some talent that they really like and
they're doing it full time and then they
can put it up online
and then the few of them that do it
provides motivation to all the other
cattle and pens that are like just stuck
there doing [ __ ] and then they're
like oh look i can look at this so i
don't have to do it
yeah yeah yeah no i know and that's one
thing that always scared me is like i'd
never i didn't want to be
like the one of the cattle people where
you just kind of like cruise yeah where
you just get like you get your job the
nine to five and you you get the salary
and you kind of follow all the steps
yeah that's necessary to then you can
kind of predict your life at that point
you've got to see where you're going
yeah where you're going to be where
you're going to live who you're going to
be friends with and how those
relationships are going to go just based
on you're just never going to get that
peak yeah you're never you're always
going to just sort of yeah you're always
going to be level-headed and then you're
going to
sympathize with people who are doing the
same thing and you're gonna make friends
with them and then you you can be
cynical together about people who have
come succeeded at things
and you can find some comfort there but
i always
it was just boring to me like
i mean i and of course i'm being
hypocritical because i'm still working
in nine to five like i'm working uh i
work as a civil engineer but i want to
be a stand-up comedian i want to be have
that be my full-time job
but if i if i knew that i was just going
to be doing civil engineering and and
working in the office
part of me just feels like that's uh
it's it's
for the rest of my life
yeah it just it doesn't feel worse it's
boring i don't know why they don't kill
themselves that's that's kind of what i
feel like yeah that's why the think too
i'm like i don't understand how that's
how you're not like freaking out but
yeah it's uh it's [ __ ] it's like
that's it's so crazy that people
actually sign up for that [ __ ] yeah but
uh yeah it makes sense because it's like
people are afraid
like you know how most people in movies
are just like doing whatever they want
but i feel like movies don't capture the
fear that most people have of their life
ending exactly it's a lot of fear it's a
ton of fear and it's a lot of um
well if they're doing it i should do it
and yeah and it's it's a lot of like
well my parents your parents they want
you to be they want that for you because
they know you'll be safe and they they
want you to have health insurance they
want you to provide for yourself just a
worldwide life
um
and there's nothing wrong with that
honestly for some people i mean there's
some people who yeah that's their dream
there's nothing wrong with
that format of job is just if you're
coerced into it or if you have no other
option than to do that then that's
[ __ ] up or if everyone is trained to
do that it's not the most useful form of
human beings and one thing that's even
harder is when it isn't
when you're doing it and you know you
don't have to
and you're fighting with yourself to
make the jump away from it so it's
almost like yeah
you're like combating yourself
while you're
while you're at the job that's what i
feel in my experience like i'll be at
the job and i'll be like you know i feel
like i'm kind of like
wasting my my life sometimes like doing
it
but
comedy like doing stand-up after work
doing it on the weekends that's like a
it's just like a nice
escape it's like it's a place investing
in yourself
yeah even if it all goes to [ __ ] at
least you worked on yourself but if you
work at a company all that work they
don't they don't have to give you
anything no they fire you they can yeah
and you're you just spent all that time
helping a company get bigger
and not working on yourself i mean you
did improve working on the company
but it's not efficient you spent most of
it working to improve the company and
not yourself yeah yeah they take it they
take advantage of you
um and it's tough to see just in offices
that i've worked in you know to see
somebody who
i yeah i've worked in one office where
this woman was there for like 40 years
and they like
they moved offices and they like she was
there for 40 years and they gave her
like this like windowless apart
office like the tiniest one in like near
next to the printer it's like
you know the management there they they
could have recognized that she's been
there for so long that they could have
given her like a nice little corner like
a little window office with a window and
stuff but it's like you see how people
treat companies treat their employees or
i do it at least i witness it and it's
just like it's kind of a bummer yeah
that's your future if you do well that's
what you could end up as and it's like
why would you sign up for that game like
the only reason is you're afraid of not
being able to make it on your own
which makes sense because they make it
as difficult to make it on your own as
possible i mean healthcare's tied to
work we have no social safety net yeah
the whole healthcare the whole
healthcare tied to work thing is
yeah that's big yeah just knowing that
you need the job for the health
insurance yeah that's it's almost like
evil yeah it's like your health like the
only thing that you need yeah it is
almost evil but that was like a
compromise they were like we're not
going to give you any health care and
then the unions were like okay what if
we got it through our work and they're
like fine yeah so it's like they we kind
of [ __ ] ourselves on that but we're
we're stuck between a rock and a hard
place you know the unions were losing
power and it's just like this is the
best we can do
yeah no it's it's um
it is a big one too is uh a lot of
people they live and i'm guilty of this
too is living with the uh
with the if i do this then i can i'll
i'll do this so if i if if i just work
this job for like 10 20 years
then i can do that thing
yeah then i can do this or
something and that's time though that's
yeah it's it's it's a that's a risky
path i think too yeah and i think this
is something that we're figuring out
recently i mean we all knew this before
but now we actually feel it and now
there's even less company benefits
there's less money flowing down so it's
like why even do it like we're it's
we're slowly waking up and being like
why don't we have an economy that works
for us instead of uh uh human beings
that work for the economy yeah yeah an
economy that works for us yeah as
opposed to yeah that's true it's it's
what is the point of this we created it
if we're just creating it just to slave
away in it yeah yeah it's almost like
it's taking control of control of us
that's why i really like what europe
europe does and i really like what what
like uh countries like norway and i
think finland and their and uh germany
dude germany has it has a really good
system where
uh for pto
in germany it's uh five by federal law
uh five weeks uh p you paid time off and
you can use it whenever you want and
there's no
social stigma against using it yeah
which is really big so like i had a
friend who was german and she said that
she's like oh yeah my parents they're
not working for the month of whatever it
was july i was like what are they like
teachers or there's another police
officers and i was like they're just
taking off the whole month of july and
she's like yeah no the the you know they
get the four they get the five weeks so
they're just gonna use four for the for
that whole month and i'm like they can
do that and she's like that's awesome
yeah yeah
i feel like uh there's like this video
these swedish police officers that
subdued this crazy guy on the new york
subway because they were on vacation and
they were like how did they all get time
and the money to fly to america like can
you imagine like i guess american police
officers make enough because some of
them make crazy amounts of money yeah
over time the garbage workers in america
getting time off to go to like yeah none
of them make enough money to take
vacation like that they don't make
enough money and they don't have the
time and they and it's stigmatized i
mean if you take a in corporate america
if you take a vacation longer than a
week you know it's bad that's a bad look
yeah it's like oh you're weak yeah we
take you over now you're weak you're uh
you're uh
yeah i'll take you over what do you
don't you don't work you think you bet
it's like you think you're better than
me that sort of thing and i think it's a
bad social stigma to to do that yeah
because it makes us overwork like it
makes it over mma you got to take time
off to rest and if you don't rest you're
not good so if you're constantly working
you're not actually constantly working
no no one is you're just droning you're
drowning on yeah and you're actually
production productivity is worse i think
yeah
yeah and uh
yeah you're just like pretending to work
and you're not actually getting a good
perspective on things and so
you're just sort of like mindlessly like
turning the levers but you're not like
doing it
with uh any sense of uh
idea of what what that's doing so if you
knew what that was for then i think
it would be easier to work harder and
stuff um but yeah i mean
the like the the swedish cops uh they
were like they didn't like tase him or
like shoot him
and i think like american cops sometimes
are rough with like poor people because
they resent having to be mental health
care professionals yep because if they
were kind and nice then the homeless
people would all come to them with their
problems be like oh help me physically
restrain me because i need it
and they don't want to do that so
they're just like give them nothing like
there's no amount of benefit that you
can get from me treating you the way
that i do because if they started giving
some sort of benefit back to the poor
then it would just be constantly
inundated with poor people that need
physical
holding or whatever
that poor people need
because like everything is the police's
job we give people no money throw them
out on the streets and the police have
to yeah they have to deal with it when
you see it on sixth street all the time
i mean yeah
crazy people just walking around uh the
homeless and the other police have to be
yeah that that mental health they have
to do everything
and i was wondering like what do you do
like for someone like that i mean is it
i don't know what they do like how they
how they can yeah i mean look at how
they're kitted they have guns and
handcuffs yeah what are they what they
don't have
cute tips no no
no no clippers they don't have
you know whatever
you can do is shoot them and time up
yeah
that's what they do
um but yeah i mean i think like uh
the office culture [ __ ] is like
toxic and stuff yeah it's just like i
think the main purpose of education and
work is to
maintain the current wealth distribution
so whatever it takes to make sure
nothing changes
like you you don't want a kid to like be
really good at
nuclear fission or
you know
uh inventing a cheaper gas
like you want them to just go to a
cubicle spend your time you know like
churning a lever arithmetically
improving
our company
and you don't want them to like coming
up with new ideas or having free time
and organizing and
starting a union so like all of our
education is designed to make sure that
nothing changes
yeah i it's interesting you say that
because pardon me is always conflicted
like the
positive side of me goes well
part of me thinks like uh well no they
do want to change then
because you know
well i guess i'll i'll put it this way
so when you see like
these programs that apple apple does or
like these billionaires do where they
want to people who are uh
let's say like uh
come from poverty and they they try to
have these like these groups or like
these um
programs to like uplift them yeah and
they have these motivational talks to
like get people from a low place to a
high place is that just for sh do you
think that's just for show like to yeah
they don't really want that they don't
really want anyone coming up too high
yeah because they want to keep their
wealth
i mean if things
shift in the lower classes i don't think
they really care that much because as
long as they're on the mountaintop and
they can just watch everything from
below just kind of move around yeah they
can move shift things around down there
but if you want it to make radical
actually
you know things that would actually help
then no they don't want that yeah
but it's just like they don't even know
what they want like they just have it
and they just want to keep it but
that's because they think that it's
better for us to not have money or
whatever
but um
yeah
i think that uh
overall their way of doing things is not
good for them
like if they wanted to preserve their
wealth the best way to be
would be to
make a better world so that there isn't
this
underclass of people that are just
seething
trying to take things over like they
they've been able to withhold us this
long so they think that
they could do it forever but
i mean
i don't think it's sustainable
they give us enough to like make us
happy most of us have played us or what
is it yes
yeah and they're like why should we have
a revolution i have a nice house i have
a nice meal and you know and all that
but like aren't you mad that you're
getting cheated like you're just happy
that you're getting
enough
like imagine all the money that they
stole from us like all the work that we
did
that they just took you know
like
aren't you mad that you're doing all
this work with more technology and
you're getting paid less than someone in
the 50s did
like all the amount of money that were
being are taken away from us is more
than what we're getting like you're so
happy with what we're getting that
you're
ignoring what they're taking from us
yeah no it is it is crazy how like uh
salaries have not really increased at
all um yeah in the whole system i mean
if you look at it if you just look at
like the stereotypical person in america
or something from middle class i mean
it's just lined up kind of hilariously
evil where it's like all right you're 18
you're going to go to college you have
to do that you get this degree it's
going to be quarter million dollars
when you leave you're going to be a
quarter million dollars in debt probably
more than that maybe 300 000 uh but now
we got to do is you just got to work
you're going to pay it off you're going
to pay it off when you're 45
and then
you're gonna start you're gonna be at
zero at 45 and then you can start saving
for retirement for 20 years and then
when you're 65 you can retire and live
with florida with your old decrepit
bones and the whole time you know you
don't you know you have to just hope
that the company that
you just have to hope that you can hold
a job and you know because and pay for
your own health insurance and everything
and
just
it's yeah it is i mean even if it did
all work out why would you want to do
that why would you want to contribute
zero to your society besides like just a
small amount you just like here's here's
my little part like why don't you want
to shake things up and be like an
important part of the society that
you're in yeah i know i mean some people
want then some people i guess i don't
know maybe some
i think that's desirable to me and i
think do you do a lot of comics to a lot
of people who are like trying to i think
the world would be a better place if we
all wanted to contribute something and
worked hard towards whatever it is
because not everyone wants to contribute
the same thing
yeah yeah it's true
but then i do talk to some people and
it's like you know i can just tell that
this person is just like
they're just
they're just kind of like
they're just
very simple
they don't
think stuff like that really right but
maybe that's a product of our education
system you think yeah the education
system or culture or just the way i mean
i'm sure those people exist but we
produce a lot more of them than there
needs to be
people who don't create things
simple yeah
because that's what we reward
if you're simple and dull you're quiet
you sit in class you do your homework
like that's what we select for and then
we create a lot of people like that
yeah no i mean yes
it's uh
it's kind of like that's what one thing
i'm like kind of like afraid of in
myself because yeah i was like i was
i don't yeah i don't want to just be
it's just at the end of the day it's
just boredom that is the real
boredom and i don't even know what it is
it's just uh
kind of fading away not really
doing anything meaningful
yeah you wanna
you wanna
impact the society that you live in
yeah i mean it feels weird to say that
like when when you say weird it sounds
like it's normal like we used to live in
hunter-gatherer tribes where we had a
huge impact we were like at least a ten
percent vote in our honor to gather
tribes now we have these giant
communities
and we feel no part or help or you know
we feel no responsibility
to it and it's not a very good feeling
we're designed to want to be a part of
something yeah yeah we are
yeah it's crazy how you can
in today's society too you can um
like really go back i was thinking about
this you could really go live a whole
life
really not talking to anybody
like you don't have to talk to a single
person nowaday like you can do all of
your telehealth through a computer with
a chat with a doctor send pictures and
everything you can work online work out
work remotely you can order all of your
groceries to your house you can whatever
you can just order everything you need
your place to be completely cut off from
society and in society so easily you can
do that and it's like
humans are not designed just
biologically to yeah
to do that it just isn't i think like
that's worse in america because we're
all immigrants to some degree or another
and we all left our
rich vast families and cultures to come
here and we're all like
you know we're all we have no culture
that's deep you know
like yeah thousand years of italian
culture whatever
no tradition really no like strong
tradition it's all a cat it's all like
yeah and so the biggest thing that gives
people so much meaning in europe we
don't have so like why should i talk to
this [ __ ] like i have nothing in
common
um yeah and that's sad
but i think it's also made worse by the
fact that our societies were developed
to [ __ ] over black people
oh america yeah in general yeah i guess
yeah i mean segregation you open up any
historic any i mean pretty much
everything yeah i mean
take like the highway system for example
yeah it's a great example like the hot
inner u.s interstate system from in the
50s
they were very
they're very open to the fact that they
were basically cutting through
uh black neighborhoods and then they
were also like
white flight splitting splitting them
and i think that was further to help
segregate black and white neighborhoods
like you see with i-35 in austin i mean
it's very clear but east and west yeah
yeah but yeah the highways and then the
white people lived in the suburbs
because like back in the day black and
white they all lived in the cities
together because they had to there was
no car yeah so you had to live near
where you work and they hated it they
were like well i don't have to live
there's so many black people living with
us and then they're like let's get the
[ __ ] out of here leave the cities for
the black people we can come in when we
have to
and then black people can't or not just
black people but like mexicans too i bet
and then like that kind of informed how
we treat poor white people too like they
got the same treatment that we gave
black people
and we just got used to having this
underclass below us that we don't want
anything to do with that we treat like
[ __ ] and they're still there they're
still gonna work for us because they
have no choice and it's just like in
europe they didn't really have that
because they didn't have chattel slavery
they don't like ship in boatloads of
foreigners to work for them so they
everyone in that
community is someone that they like
so you would never
build a highway through some you know
some neighborhood and then live far away
and then come in because like why would
you do that everyone here is flemish or
whatever yeah
except for the jews
they hated the jews yeah they did they
really did yeah
yeah now that they had
feel like that's why we're so
psychotically evil to poor people is
just because we practiced
with the underclass that we have of
minorities
yeah it's like the whole his it's like
the whole
basically the whole thing of
america and uh is basically just like
exploitation it is yeah it's like it's
like they wanted to go into the middle
of nowhere they came from bach and
mozart and [ __ ] you know leonardo da
vinci and like civilization and they're
like i want to go to georgia
and live on a plantation and have slaves
work for me like that's that's crazy
well the crazy thing is
now is that we still have that it's but
now our slaves are we don't even see
them we i don't know we don't even call
them slaves
that's the thing is like
the stuff that's all in here this room
this phone
it's like it all came from overseas
with slavery i believe but
i don't know i don't know what it looks
like
but it's still it's good yeah it's bad
it's like as much as we can get with
paying as little as possible yeah yeah
so it's like
are we gonna go like i was thinking this
like
the way that i viewed slaves and where
china and they make our stuff now is
that similar to somebody who was in like
new york city in like the 1820 who was
looking at
the stuff that he had and or they had
like from the south
is it like the same thing where it's
like well i don't know i don't witness
it i don't know where these play i've
heard about the plantations i've heard
about it i don't i'm not i don't know
and then you've we get more information
about with pictures and newspapers and
then you go oh this is [ __ ] up this is
bad like why and then the civil war i
think that's going to happen
with us with with what china china i
think we're going to we're meeting you
people in america we're going to be
starting to be like this is kind of
[ __ ] up like what's going on over
there
that's better to be like oh things are
[ __ ] up but i still have to do it then
to be like well who cares i can't do
anything that's just [ __ ] party like
yeah that's the worst no that is bad
yeah because that's like not doing
anything and not having the right
mindset while you're not doing anything
at least if you're not doing anything
about it but you have like you feel bad
about it then that's better than [ __ ]
because it's a joy
yeah
enjoying the the horrible [ __ ] that's
going on because it's so easy to make
fun of liberals they're like oh they
talk like they want to help black people
but they're not doing anything but
that's better than not helping black
people and not wanting to help black
people
yeah i guess if you look at it in a
progression it's better to get to that
point and then kind of move more to
where you actually start doing something
than to not but people nowadays are just
too
focused on their own hedonistic
pleasures they just want like their dick
sucked and they smoke a vape and listen
to a podcast yeah i mean have their
[ __ ] cleaned yesterday yeah that's
the thing is like
you
can
really
like just be a hedonist if you want if
you want to there's no law against it i
personally i i'm i'm very like uh
i don't know self-critical and stuff
like that so i don't
i don't know if that's even the right
word
you're too i'm self-conscious so
self-conscious and self-aware to like do
stuff like that but yeah you can
literally live a life of you know eat
whatever drink whatever smoke whatever
do the drugs
get you know if you wanted to in america
that's one thing you can really easily
do
yeah that's what we're designed to do
it's easier to separate us that way just
be like focus on yourselves and then the
whole thing is going to [ __ ]
and i think it's great that people want
to focus on themselves and improve
themselves but at some point you got to
improve the society around you yeah it's
not always you
you can't always just muscle your way
out of every issue
some point your society around you has
to improve too yeah it's the
environment's big one one thing i was
just thinking about was like uh with it
was austin and the fact that like
you know i drive around austin's
probably has so much money i have to
guess with all the people moving here
with excuse me with all the corporations
here i was thinking they should start uh
really like improving this the roads
here the roads are awful just like
driving around the roads are so bad it's
like that's one thing that can make
living here
so much nicer right but the it's the
whole infrastructure that needs to be
fixed because there's so many roads yeah
there's so many and it's so
inefficiently spaced out that if you
wanted to improve the roads it'd cost
unbelievable yes but if everyone was
packed in then you'd only need to
improve one road to improve life's the
life for 100 000 people
right now you have to improve like a
whole neighborhood
yeah you know it's just so many roads
driving around it literally driving
around austin when you're not on like a
highway
for me it feels like i'm driving like
like all terrain like the roads are
like bumpy and like potholes and
like uh yeah yeah i mean it's not even
their fault like if you pave everything
over like that's why trains are so much
better
like it's just a rail you got to focus
on two rails if you want to improve a
street you got to pave over it like four
lanes a lot no it's a lot of work yeah a
lot of layers it's expensive
yeah
if only there were more trains in austin
yeah
i always end up talking about trains
um
what do you want to do you want to
7 18. are you going to texas sake
uh i was i didn't get i wasn't able to
get on the list i messaged him about
standby i don't think i don't think he
uh responded
but what other mics are going on tonight
i was gonna do the the snail haven one
uh but then i was dude we're gonna do
this uh i did what time is snail haven
that was at 6 15. it might have [ __ ]
might as well still be going on uh where
is it it's at his new place he he sent
me the address i have it on my it's like
uh
south austin it's like uh right near
zilker
oh nice place i was uh like barton
spring yeah that area and then there's
springs
so there was that then there's the sake
then there's i think the only other one
is uh the midnight mic on congress
but
i don't know if i'll do that one which
one's the midnight is that the one that
victor martinez runs yeah it's outside
yeah yeah does that by the taco yeah
okay on the street yeah
yeah i'm probably not gonna do that one
yeah no i did it once before never at
midnight but i did it before it's it's
fun but it's it's uh
it's it's like people just walking by
and you're just friday night mics are
hard they are everyone's partying yeah
and bars don't really want you there
yelling
you know being autistic and theater kid
yeah energies while everyone's partying
yep they don't want that yeah saturdays
are the worst fridays are second worst
and then everything else is pretty evil
yeah it's pretty cool the world is
partying that's when we rest you work
yeah that's why i like the buzzmill mic
so much because it was friday yeah and
it was at 11 where everybody else was
out like doing things
yeah and this was like a nice little
time to just like
do stand up with people who are there to
just hang out and drink and what are
they doing there now i don't know i
don't know
we i'm going to talk to
i think raymond raymond was the host i
think he had to connect
so be cool to to see if we can get that
going up again
uh at some point but
yeah
yeah that's important mics are important
yeah
so what do you think about uh
you know the uh abortion
decision
oh the six weeks thing yeah uh six weeks
is way too uh
way too uh soon yeah yeah it's too much
it's not even the first it's the second
trimester of the first trimester yeah
yeah no i think it's too much and i
think it's uh
it is it's like a step back
in uh because they repealed all roe v
wade um yeah
it's like a step back in time that i
never thought i would see i never
thought i would see that something so
such a such a big conservative shift i
know everything's been liberal for the
like a big liberal shifts for the past
marriage and weed yeah it's all been
going in that direction so to see
something like that
this
was sorry ladies we want to smoke weed
we want to [ __ ] each other in the butt
we're going to have to you know two
steps forward one step back
yeah no i it i mean
and weren't they talking about repealing
the gay marriage uh yeah do you think
they like take away uh birth control do
you think they're gonna do that
i hope so
i hope they do that because then that
maybe that'll get people to
rebel like see what's going on yeah like
the liberals are bad but the
conservatives are way worse
yeah it's it's crazy
they're all about wealth preservation
and they just want to distract with
these issues and they're like oh this is
the way that the people with all the
wealth live their life is with through
god and not smoking and not having being
gay i always thought those people were i
was under the impression those people
were just dying out and it didn't exist
as much anymore but i guess it's still
going strong and they're going for the
fine
the last to get it all out because
that's push you guys are all gonna die
i'll be dead go away like the dinosaurs
so it doesn't really matter what you do
now because
40 years from now you guys are all gonna
be gone most rational people
i feel like most rational people are
cool with abortion
that's a good question are you cool with
abortion like are you all right with it
yeah it's it's dope
i mean yeah you gotta kill babies you
can't just let every baby live yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah no it's it's like
that's what they think about people it's
just cattle it's just crop they don't
care the quality of humans that come out
they just want more more of them more
and more of them yeah
yeah i mean what are your thoughts on
the death sentence though
um
a lot of people that i respect don't
like the death sentence because it's
like barbaric that a society kills
people that you have that level of like
you know if you could if you go that far
low then
it just brings everything down yeah and
how you treat people yeah
i uh
i don't agree with the death sentence
one of the crazy because i was always
kind of on the fence but the craziest
thing i ever like the most
the thing that pushed me towards being
against it was i was watching this thing
called on youtube called soft white
underbelly have you ever seen that no
it's this guy he takes pictures of he's
a photographer by trade but he started
to want to look into the story of the
person he was taking the pictures of so
it was really interesting so he you take
pictures of them and he would start to
talk learn about their life
and so he had one that was really cool
it was about a in
an incested family in appalachia
and one of the guys was so inbred
that he her family yeah but one of the
person one of the people that he
interviewed was a warden who was in
charge of in the south who was in charge
of the death
killing the people
and he talked about all the steps
involved and he was very just like
calm about it and he talked about you
know yeah we have to you shave their
ankles you shave the wrists
you uh you know give them their last
words they spent time with their family
and he was going through all the little
minutia of killing this person and just
seeing it in my head and learning how
the sausage is made so to speak i was
like yeah this is really [ __ ] up that
we do this as a society yeah that we
and he was like yeah so i usually we
usually take them out at 11 59
p.m and we have somebody at the phone um
upstairs uh waiting for a call from the
governor
because the governor can pardon them at
any time they want they want yeah isn't
that crazy the governor that's so
unhealthy for the guy getting murdered
like i don't know if i'm gonna get
murdered today yeah and then like yep
it's a go no wait wait i thought i
thought the camera
and he pulls a lever yeah yeah it's just
barbaric and to like think of the dmv
killing someone because that's what it
sounds like
just from how you described it it's like
a very
bureaucratic process like first you
could do this on that yeah and then it
ends up in death it's like that should
never be the case
yeah
yeah it's
it's just
so
it's it's like if we can do that we can
do anything like if we can just kill
someone yeah like somewhere within that
chain of command you should be like
maybe this isn't
necessary
but if we can't even come to that
conclusion through all these steps and i
think we're lost i think there's
something wrong yeah
yeah now it's
yeah
excuse me the um then there's also
assisted suicide there's people who want
to
that's not the same thing this yeah it's
not the same thing at all yeah but it's
like
i was talking to somebody about this
it's totally actually it's a different
topic entirely but i was talking to
somebody about this
and that makes sense somebody who wants
to who has a terminal illness and it's
just
to mitigate suffering
yeah
that's important people should die
yep
if they want to die honestly yeah it's
just like this idea of human beings is
just like vassals for their lord
and like oh we might need you to fight
off the huns so don't kill yourself yet
it's like this isn't
the person isn't
uh
uh
a tool for the society
um you know like a person should have
autonomy or else it's like what's the
point of
um
you know like if if you have outlived
your usefulness to society or even if
you haven't like
it should be your life to decide we
don't need all hands on deck anymore
it's not like we need everyone to be
chopping wood and if we did need
everyone chopping wood then people
wouldn't feel so hopeless and want to
kill themselves
but we're living in a society that
doesn't need everyone yeah it doesn't
need anybody and now we're not even
letting them die at the time they want
to
yeah that's a big one is not having
things for people to do that can [ __ ]
with your head because we are meant to
do things and like build stuff like i
feel like that's just biologic biology
like you're meant to be around people
and you're meant to like do stuff that's
why we have like video games is a
relaxing thing for people but it's
they're doing something yeah if you if
you
are at your job and they're not giving
you anything to do but you also have to
look busy
and you do that for eight hours a day
that that'll [ __ ] with your head i mean
i've never folks with my head the whole
purpose of a person is to make something
and then to not even make something but
pretend to make something yeah no it's
yeah that's what i do because it's like
i'm
i realize that i'm i'm a con engineering
consultant or like a consulting so they
want me to
they
they are incentivized for me to be there
because for every
dollar i make they're making two or
three dollars yeah they're charging the
client so it's like they're just happy
that they just want me to be there so
it's like
you know sometimes they they're not
giving me stuff to do like i need stuff
to do i need stuff to do and it's like
when you don't have something to do and
you want to be productive but you
they're not you don't really have
anything it it and you're in the cubicle
and you're in the office and it's like
yeah you're my my mind goes to a point
where it's like i feel like i'm in like
a solitary confinement
kind of
yeah i mean it's like
using your creative mind to do
uncreative things
you're using literally like not doing
anything and you have to be creative
about how you not do it not do anything
yeah yeah i mean you you were an
engineer right yeah for a little bit for
how long
like a year
and it was that right out of school yeah
and then when did you go
full-time stand-up after that yeah
no date no other jobs no day jobs or
anything really no okay
and yeah
that's
that's commendable like the and i was
thinking that i don't know if i have the
balls to do that yet to just to just
jump out of it
yeah i just had a profound disrespect
for this society that i lived in i was
like i don't need to contribute i don't
want to contribute you don't need me
like what are we working towards if we
were working towards going to space or
something yeah then i'd be all
gung-ho and happy to be doing it if if
kami didn't exist what would you be
doing you think if stand-up wasn't a
thing like if it just didn't exist um
maybe just like doing van life in the
desert or you know making like little
wooden figurines or ceramic pots
or making something
ceramic pots yeah
like art like artisans yes craftsmanship
making something
um
or like just trying to hasten the
downfall of a corrupt society
staging uh strikes and
organizing
workers to finance their bosses yeah
yeah
that's the only thing that really
makes sense to me
yeah so yeah van life and kind of
meaningful things yeah
yeah i mean i'd hope so i'd probably
just end up with a normal job just
trying to survive trying to buy a nice
tv and stuff
but hopefully i'd be an underground
warrior
fighting against
the
moneyed powers
um but yeah i mean you want to do comedy
would you i would i was singing music as
well but music is so
it's so much about looks you think yeah
like what you look like yeah but it's
also about ed sheeran
that you're in adele
um
but then everyone else is hot
yeah i guess so
i'm trying to think
well yeah especially pop music yeah it's
big like olivia rodrigo or
jack harlow ariana grande
yeah
yeah but then there's something i want
to aretha franklin though you know
yeah there's like you got to be really
good yeah they're very talented
and it's just such a
feeling based
uh art form
i'd rather like think my way out of a
problem i don't think our current
solutions required
require a feeling
i think it's better to think
i think feelings are great and they're
powerful but they're too
uh
loose
thoughts can be directed
and be pointed
and i think that's what we need so music
is too much feeling yeah it's not
concrete i love music i love uh
i would love to be well you're like 24.
24 yeah young people are like more
connected to that [ __ ]
yeah like hey man why don't we just feel
no no but i'm i'm more thinking though
that's me like in that what is that the
the
tj
or whatever
the introverted the myers-briggs
i'm you know that's all [ __ ] right i
mean it's yeah it's probably like zodiac
signs but for uh whatever it's probably
the same thing but uh but i am more of a
i always thought i was more of a thinker
i don't know i'm not a big feeler i
don't feel much yeah yeah which is good
and bad
yeah it is bad though because it's like
i want to feel more
in general but it's good i think to also
give for the
i mean
i look at the people that feel and
they're a mess they're always yeah no
that's the thing that's probably why i
don't really
they're being led astray they're like oh
i feel like this now oh i feel like that
no it's like you have no
sort of concrete foundation yeah
yeah now people who are all gas pedal on
feeling and emotion it usually is
entertaining to what witness a lot of
time
it's cool to see but i don't think they
end up feeling better no i don't know i
don't it's because their lives are a
mess yeah their lives are a mess and uh
but they're a slave to their emotions
yeah they don't know what they're going
to feel next i know that whatever i feel
next will be in line with my goal of
world domination
yeah yeah there you go
yeah
yeah i mean i think it takes both um but
i think like we are too feely i think
our intellectual side has atrophied as a
society and we're all like more
emotional yeah we're all about like feel
good man yeah and that doesn't solve
anything
yeah it's a big one feel good you know
it's like uh
all these companies they sell you
the emotion you know what is it
coca-cola buy happiness or try a little
happiness or something
um
yeah it's big and
you fall into that traffic and
it leads to a hangover like anything
that feels good it has a hangover
booze or
anything food
yeah it's not a solid meal you can't
feed yourself just on you know satiating
your urges
you gotta like actually like do
something and create something new
instead of just like trying to get rid
of pain or
just feel good all the time
and i feel like if you just focus on
feeling good you're not going to feel
good you're just going to
you're going to like
you know it
you're not thinking long term if you
think more you're gonna think long term
and then like plan ahead and then you're
gonna have more long-term happiness as
opposed to like short-term just
chasing the next high the next high yeah
yeah
kind of delayed gratification
putting things off
yeah
so do you think like a lot of comics are
feely or dinky it depends on the comic i
think i think they're more thinking yeah
i think the more thinking i think if
you're a feely comic you don't really uh
you don't last because you just you get
sense that you get uh
yeah you just don't i don't think if
you're if you're too feeling you
you just don't do it i don't think and
you don't uh have the ability to put
your thoughts into words you're just
sort of up there just like you guys need
to feel like me
and it's also arrogant to just be like i
have the best feelings because then you
never have to test it at least thoughts
you can put it on paper
and like compare and contrast and get
better
but feelings are just subjective
yeah the feeling though part of the
interesting thing about feeling though
it's like it's almost like it's the you
could have a thought but sometimes a
thought isn't anything without the
feeling attached to it
it adds like a soul to it like i always
bring up louis as an example but because
he's my favorite comic but he has these
amazing thoughts in my opinion but he
adds
with the feeling that you could tell
that he has he adds the emotion to it so
like
the thought itself is funny but when he
says it with the feeling because he you
can tell he's a very emotional stand-up
comedian it adds another layer to it
that makes it really pop yeah i mean
it's all impossible to not have feeling
yeah you have feelings all the time
so like yeah it's not like that i'm a
purely robot
uh it's like there's feelings attached
to everything and it doesn't have to be
so on the nose and so exaggerated for
like if you're so good at feeling then
you should be able to sense that there
is a feeling behind the thoughts
and uh if you're just like a feeling
supremacist and you're just like
no this doesn't have enough feeling for
me because you you're not looking for it
you're just like you you think that only
you have
the right feelings
so you don't see it in others you know
you're not doing it the right way
yeah you talk you you're talking about
like the um when you say feeling on
stage you're talking about like like the
kind of like the
when they're trying when they're feeling
away like when they're showing a
reaction to a certain subject and
they're like trying to get the audience
on board with that
reaction like that feeling that's not
what i was talking about but what do you
mean interesting
no like uh if if someone's like thinks
that they're like better at feeling than
other people and they they see someone
thinking and they're like oh that
doesn't have enough feeling well it does
have feeling you just are too caught up
in your feelings to see feelings in
other people
and it's like you should
be able to as an expert in feeling sense
the feelings and thoughts like there's
no thoughts without feelings and there's
no feelings without thoughts
and i think it's it goes both ways you
know like you can see someone feeling
and be like oh this guy has no thought
but there is a thought behind it
even though it's even if it's you know
vague and covered up by a bunch of
[ __ ]
but yeah i mean um
yeah i think that uh some people that
feel on stage are gross and boring
they don't really know how to make the
audience feel the way that they're
feeling they can only feel the way that
they're feeling they don't know how to
make other people feel that way
um but yeah i mean i think it's better
to be a thinker because then at least
it's in words
and you can convey
your thoughts into other people's heads
and then maybe they can have the
feelings instead for you
but yeah it depends
yeah yeah
i i see that i mean it's so you can
break the breaking down the semantics of
it too you can kind of go down different
avenues
and the difference between the two but
yeah it's it's
you can't really have one without the
other
yeah but if you if you go fully on one
especially the feeling yeah it can be
destructive as a for a comedian yeah
but
i just don't trust it i just feel like
some people that are all into feelings
are just into themselves
yeah no someone who's really into
themselves just in general as a
personality trait is is uh unattractive
to me
over over uh
being self-absorbed but yeah and it's
easy it's easy to do on social that's
part of the reason i try to look at
social media lessons because it's not
necessarily to do it on purpose
because they're just posting something
about themselves but it for me like it
comes across as being self-absorbed
sometimes depending on the context but
it's not the case it's just what i'm
seeing
because i'm only seeing
that aspect of that
but anyway um but yeah
all right
you want to call it a podcast
uh sure
okay um anything you want to say yeah
thanks for having me man this it was a
fun surprise
to
to do this and i would love to do it
again anytime just let me know